saying anything to your team
yes
[Music]
good evening everyone the time 7 30 so
and tonight where i start the standards
committee meeting
i'm just going to read out the emergency
evacuation announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building right
via the rear doors to the hall turn
right go through the two sets of double
doors to the car park
which is the assembly point please do
not delay
your evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to the
building until given permission to
do so by the council staff please note
that the meeting will be audio recorded
please switch off any mobiles
or turn them to silent
members there are four microphones on
the tables for use during the meeting
when i invite you to speak please wait
until there is a microphone in front of
you
before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing loop
and for the audio recording where
possible please
help by passing microphones to each
other and use the hand
gel and anti-material wipes on the
tables if you do touch the microphones
members voting will be done on a show of
hands
in line with the constitution i will
ask for a show of hands and then against
the recommendations numbers not voting
will be noted by the officers
agenda item number one apologies for
absence
um apologies have been received from
councillor tony carter mrs tony carter
agenda item two substitute members
councillor
mrs christine mason is substituting for
councillor mrs tony carter
thank you mrs christine mason
agenda drive to number three non-members
attending
we welcome tonight councillor mr chris
stanley
agenda item number four minutes of the
meeting held on the 24th
of march are the minutes agreed
members yes councillor
[Music]
constable
[Music]
thank you council mrs constable where
amend those
are there any more indications for any
inaccuracies
or comments
thank you members i'll take those as
agreed
gender item number five to receive
declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
members
no one has indicated thank you so
moving on to a gender item number six
the standards committee working group
and our officer sonia washington will
present the officers report for us
[Music]
members council on the 19th of february
2020
determined that the composition
of the member train working group uh be
decided
and constituted by the standards
committee
starting from the next municipal year
onwards i.e with effect from
the last municipal year from 2020 to 21.
last year the working group was was
determined by this committee
and it comprised six members
the members were counsellors mrs
mcpherson
mrs gooding mrs lumley stanley
steptoe and wilson working groups do not
have to be drawn for members of the
standards committee
any member of the council can be invited
to be working group members
there has been a considerable change in
membership of the standards committee
this year
and members may want to consider some
continuity and membership
of the of the working group perhaps
retaining some of last year's members if
there if they're willing to
continue ultimately however
it is for this committee sitting here
this evening
to determine the membership of its of
its own working group
thank you
thank you sonya um members have you got
any questions
please counselor mr
is it a question anybody got any
questions at the moment on the paper
okay members um there's one
recommendation as you can see in
paragraph 5.1 on
6.1 of the report
and that is at this committee determines
the membership of the sanders committee
working groups of the 2021-22 municipal
year
um i did ask our officer to email out
to members of the working group from
last year
asking if they would be interested in
saying
on the committee i'm pleased to say that
councillors
um mrs june lamely and councillor mr
stuart wilson and i must give credit to
councillor mr stuart wilson for his
contribution
towards the um internet i.t
survey that has recently come around
it's been a great help on that working
group
and of course um also our independent
member
councillor mr sheppard
thank you um so i would like to
recommend
um that councillors uh mrs june lumley
and councillor stuart wilson um and
councillor mr shadow
all remain on the working group have i
got
a second athlete thank you very much
thanks councillor mr dre
thank you
have we got other nominations for the
working group
have some strategy
um
[Music]
thank you uh council mrs mason
thank you um
um
already indicated he wants to speak
thank you very much
and should be willing to stand here
and she hasn't indicated to us so yes
we'll follow
that thank you
[Music]
and it's the only agenda item and uh
council mr stanley please thank you
thank you
thank you and councilman
mr gary myles
thank you and so sonia could you
is that the list
yeah i'm just gonna
uh with me i'm just going to read out
the list and if everybody is in favor i
will
then ask you to indicate um on the
working group
there will be myself councillor trey
councillor mrs june lumley councillor mr
wilson
mr shepherd councillor mr
fd councilman mr gooding
council mr stanley councillor mr myers
and councillor mrs carter subject to her
agreement
could i have a vote on that please if
you could indicate
yeah that's unanimous chairman
thank you that's unanimous
and that members concludes the business
for this evening
and the meeting is closed at 8 40.
thank you all very much for coming out
this evening
thank you